[Musique]
nous profitons aujourd'hui de l'export
habitation s'est adonné paix pour faire
goûter un hors d'oeuvre classique quand
on invite les gens à la maison et j'ai
nommé les zones où il y en a des
soutiens on a des grosses y en a des
vertus en a des noirs y en a avec noyau
ayant donné farcissez ce qu'on goûte
aujourd'hui quatre compagnies
différentes
unico qu'il a reçus de rotation et choix
du président en place dégustation
allez vous voyez vous des bonnes
références
la console
la couronne s'est pas passé comme on
achète les olives avec des noyaux ou les
indices ne savez vous la différence
entre une allée verte journal est venue
de la maturité de l'eau les
[Musique]
pour dia phare en est la propriétaire de
la boutique
olivier au lit si vous vous mordez un
jour dans une oliveraie jeu vous allez
faire ce juste une fois dans votre vie
parce que c'est extrêmement amer on doit
les faire macérer dans de l'eau xl ou de
l'acide citrique pour en retirer
l'amertume alors des fois ça peut jouer
aussi dans le tout de celle de nos
livres lorsqu'on la gauche
l'eau du robinet pour la rentrée
sur la menzogna c'est pour les espagnols
ce qu'est la callas marca pour les grecs
la même année à son nom vient de ma nana
qui est la pomme en espagnol et puis en
début de saison la menzogna comme on la
voit dans l'arbre et les rondelles et
verte
on pourrait avoir l'impression que c'est
une pommette si vous voulez c'est une
nuit une olive cappone haute teneur en
huile est vraiment la ligue nationale
c'est celle qu'on vous servir un départ
dans des restaurants les olives de table
qui doit juste mais ça décape le fond de
la gorge a ici pour quelques grammes on
à 13%
ce diable quand même ce sont les olives
les plus salées de notre échantillon
[Musique]
plus d'amertume
c'est la verte que coûte
c'est alors que j'ai préféré
c'est pas que jaillisse la meo après ça
il faut l'apéritif a personnellement
cela va de soi d'ailleurs vous risquez
vous et quel sort que ses proches de la
marque unique au du jamais vu ces unités
la manière on va surtout la travailler
quand elle est verte
donc elle devrait avoir une chaque et
plus plus ferme et c'est aussi une ligue
petit noyau donc comme le producteur en
a pour son argent
et nous aussi comme consommateurs ont pu
dénoter à l'occasion un petit goût
d'amande un petit goût de noix
comme textures et les grosses moi je
pensais
exxon est trop salée pour moi oui j'en
touche moi pas que ça monte tous ici ce
serait la vue le choix du président plus
grosse que la manne vanilla la variété
gorda lé porte aussi le nom de livre n
quant aux thermes colossal
il désigne la grosseur de l'onu j'arrive
qui viennent du même pays d' italie en
espagne en 2007 olivier de la grèce et
sans être indiquée sur le pot il s'agit
de la variété halles qui dit qui j'ai
aimé la rouge parce que à se démarquer
dans le ponde et détroit
la louche qu'elle avait de particulier
c'est la seule des quatre qui est un
véritable poids morceaux de poivrons à
la table
rozon que c'est de la pâte de port le
plus de caractère plus marqués et trois
ans que pauvres de france
il ya des grandes différences dans nos
résultats 4 goûteurs ont choisi les
coraux nation 5 ont préféré les uniques
aux traits sont allés du côté de choix
du président mais vraiment le grand
gagnant aujourd'hui et pilar ans avec 28
votes
merci à tout le monde et bientôt
[Musique]